ich habe die schlechteste Bar in ganz
Berlin getestet um zu schauen ob es dort
wirklich so schlecht ist wie im Internet
beschrieben die neue Odessa Bar in
Berlin sticht mit gerade mal 2,8 Sternen
und über 1000 Bewertungen wirklich
absolut als schlechteste Bar heraus
erste beschweren sich online über
komische Leute in der Bar die Getränke
sind viel zu teuer eine ihre Frau an der
Tür und die Türsteher gehen gar nicht ob
das wirklich so ist wollte ich unbedingt
herausfinden so Leute hier sind war neue
und deshalb war sieht auch wieder
eigentlich sehr einladend aus von
draußen zumindest gehen wir mal rein
in Berlin